horizon 2020 now it's not the title of
the latest science fiction film released
at the cinema it's one of the e u--'s
most ambitious funding programs its goal
is to boost research and innovation in
the European Union over a period of
seven years horizon 2020 will not be
limited to the academic world it will
also provide support for businesses how
by allocating four percent of its budget
more than three billion euros and by
simplifying the procedures for funding
applications one of the reasons to help
bring European discovery into the
marketplace and move from frontier
research to economic opportunities we
have many situations where something an
idea a concept is developed the
researches of la piña up and this give
rise to a product that is produced
somewhere else in the world even when
the market is back in Europe and we want
to avoid this social innovation is also
one of the objectives included in the
program the aim is to fight poverty in
the EU however for some Emmy Peas
there's not enough of a focus on this
area it must be said that the parliament
has wished to designate 100 billion
euros to the horizon 2020 program in the
end they got just 70 billion el
parlamento cree profundamente que llora
Cortes pursue post Aereo's sobre todo de
poca de décès no deben effect are a que
las materias que como la investigación
de innovation la educación estan en la
vache de nuestra capacidad de
crecimiento y de nuestra competitive
edad innovative SMEs in Europe can issue
one or several applications for funding
for projects linked to its area of
activity a major new feature of this is
that a business will from now on be able
to apply independently